in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit. Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 22nd, on which we commemorate,
our righteous Father, Theodore of Sikeon. On the 22nd of the month,
we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father, Theodore of Sikeon,
Bishop of Anastasiopolis.
Our Holy Father, Theodore, was born during the reign of Justinian from the union
of an imperial courier with a prostitute named Mary in the village Inn of Sikeon,
in the region of Ankara, in Galatia. At the moment of his conception,
his mother saw a great luminous star which descended into her womb,
assured by holy men that the child would become great in the eyes of God.
She abandoned her disreputable profession and led an honorable life,
and after the child had been baptized under the name of Theodore,
which means gift of God, she took care to give him a good education.
When he was six years old, she planned to have him enter the service of the Emperor,
but the great martyr George appeared to her and said,
the Heavenly Emperor has need of him.
Being sent to school, Theodore displayed excellent aptitudes for study
and knew how to make himself loved by his companions,
without, however, joining in their childish pranks.
Possessed of a great spiritual zeal through the influence of a virtuous and devout servant,
he developed the habit of not returning to the house at lunchtime,
but fasted for the whole day, guided by Saint George,
who appeared to him in the form of a young man.
He would go to the chapel of the great martyr, which was situated on a neighboring hill,
to pray and meditate on holy scripture in silence.
When evening came, he visited the churches,
and it was late at night that he would make a meal of boiled wheat bread.
At other times, Saint George would come to him in the middle of the night,
chasing away the demons, which had placed themselves in his path,
and taking him to the chapel to pass the night in vigil.
At first, his mother sought to prevent this,
but after Saint George appeared to her,
she let her son pursue his ascetic labors.
Theodore therefore began to spend long periods in silence and seclusion with God alone,
and he thus learned to battle against demonic temptations.
His soul aim was to run towards Christ, of whom he had become the imitator.
He followed in his footsteps like a huntsman tracking his prey,
mortifying his body, as though it were a stranger to him.
As he had undertaken with difficulty to learn the Psalms,
he begged God to help him, and received the grace of being able to easily learn the Psalter by heart in a few days.
As soon as he heard word of a man of God,
he would set out to visit him to learn about his manner of life,
and receive a portion of his grace.
At the age of fifteen, he decided to pass the whole of his life
henceforth in the chapel of Saint George.
He dug a vault under the altar,
where he would stay from the Theophany to Palm Sunday,
eating only a little fruit on Saturdays and Sundays.
The holy martyr gave him the power to heal sickness and to chase away demons,
fleeing from their victims, the latter would cry out,
woe to us, for we are chased away by an infant.
Great distress will come upon us through this sun of a prostitute.
In order to undertake further spiritual battles,
Theodore dug a cave in the mountain,
where he remained hidden and unknown to anyone for two years.
His mother finally discovered him and took him back to the chapel of Saint George,
covered like a new Job in wounds in which vile worms had lodged.
When the Bishop of Anastasiopolis heard with admiration of the exploits accomplished by this young man,
he, without taking the canonical regulations into consideration,
conferred on him all the holy orders,
so that the people of God might not be further deprived of his blessing.
Theodore then increased his modifications to conform himself to Christ,
the high priest, who offered himself in his passion for the salvation of the world.
He made a pilgrimage on foot to Jerusalem,
visited the monasteries and the ascetics of the desert,
and, while staying at the monastery of Kosovo,
received the holy monastic habit.
When he returned to Galatia, two disciples came to join him in the chapel of Saint George
to form a harmonious and god-pleasing choir.
Grace shone from Theodore as from a new Moses,
and through his prayers, fasts, vigils, and valiant modifications.
He healed the sicknesses and cast out the demons of all the faithful who came to ask his intercession.
Unsatisfied, however, with his accustomed asceses,
he had a very narrow iron cage built,
and spent his time of solitude during the great fast there.
He would also load himself with a heavy cuirass weighing fifty pounds,
and tie a heavy iron cross around his neck,
and metal rings around his hands and feet,
rings which remained on his body until his death.
Thus, defying nature, he remained in this cage in the open air,
standing immobile until the evening, and singing the praises of God.
When the temperature froze, his feet would be stuck fast to the ground by the ice.
On another occasion, he fainted through exposure to the sun.
These exploits accomplished through pure love of God,
and not through the desire to receive the praise of men,
constrained the Lord to multiply the gifts of his grace to him.
Animals trustingly approached the cage to receive some titbit from the ascetics hand,
and if the demons tried to attack him, they were repulsed by a divine fire which emanated from him.
But the saint was not exempt from the weakness of our nature,
and one day, falling gravely ill, he shed abundant tears,
thinking that he had not yet completed his repentance,
and that he was going to leave his disciples without a shepherd.
Through the intercession of St. Cosmos and Damien,
he was healed, and was able to take up again with zeal,
his askecies, and his spiritual guidance.
The community grew, and many of those who had been possessed,
and then delivered by St. Theodore, asked to remain with him.
The chapel of St. George became too small,
and a beautiful church dedicated to the Archangel Michael was built,
in which the monks gave themselves to the praise of God.
Theodore placed his disciple Philomenos at the head of the community
in order to be able to escape from concern with temporal affairs,
and to remain without distraction in the presence of God.
His wonder-working prayer became the refuge of the whole region.
It brought rain in time of drought, led the river back on its course in time of flood,
chased away locusts, and other calamities from the crops,
multiplied flour in times of shortage, and above all healed the sick and the possessed,
who would spend whole days waiting for divine favor.
In order to receive the crowds who came to the monastery,
the saint was forced to transform the chapel,
which had been the arena of his first battles, into a vast and sumptuous church,
to the construction of which he contributed by numerous miracles.
On the death of the Bishop of Anastasiopolis, the clergy and leading citizens
went to ask the Metropolitan of Ankara to make Theodore Bishop.
Taken by force to Ankara, he was consecrated against his will,
and shown fenceforth like a radiant star spreading the grace of God over his diocese,
both by his miracles and by his alms and spiritual instruction.
Making himself all things to all men, he was a living model of Christian perfection,
and taught that holiness remains accessible to all those who desire it.
Wade down, however, by pastoral cares,
he reckoned that the episcopal charge had deprived him of the blessed freedom
from care of the monastic life, and he dreamed of resigning.
During a further pilgrimage to Jerusalem, he wished to remain there in Isihia,
but Saint George appeared to him to remind him of his responsibilities
while promising to release him from them at an opportune time.
On returning to Anastasiopolis, seeing that the people remained objuret in their lacks ways,
and encouraged in his decision by Assyrian ascetic,
he presented his resignation to the Metropolitan after an episcopate of eleven years.
But the Metropolitan, maintaining that he could not find a successor to such a virtuous man,
refused to accept his request.
Theodore then made an appeal to the Holy Patriarch Kiriakos
and to Emperor Maurice, whose accession to the throne the Saint had predicted to him
and obtained their permission to retire to his monastery,
while keeping the insignia of the episcopate.
They both invited him to Constantinople where he was received with honor
and where he accomplished many miracles, casting out demons
and healing one of the sons of the Emperor who was ill with elephantiasis.
On his return to the monastery, he decided to remain to the end of his years in Isihia.
In addition to the miracles which flowed from him like an inexhaustible spring,
he also showed himself a wise physician,
counseling each one who approached him on the detailed remedies it was necessary to swallow,
or the surgery or courses it was necessary to undergo.
More than this, he was a physician of souls, prescribing the penance it was necessary
to perform for those who showed to him the sicknesses hidden in their hearts
and revealing their sins to those who concealed them from him,
exhorting them to let themselves be treated.
He reconciled those who were divided by hate
and unceasingly exhorted everyone to disdain earthly possessions,
the cause of all divisions among Christians,
and to grow in fraternal charity the bond of perfectness.
He delivered the poor from tax collectors and moneylenders,
and encouraged everyone to practice hospitality and almsgiving,
through which they could obtain the forgiveness of their sins.
He predicted that the emperor Maurice would be assassinated in the year 602 and replaced by Falkus.
Then, during a second stay in the capital,
he announced to patriarch Thomas in the year's 607 through 610,
that great calamities would break out in the empire.
The patriarch who looked on him as a brother constrained the saint to prolong his stay during Lent.
Theodore shot himself up for his accustomed retreat in a monastery,
and he supported the dying prelate with his prayers,
with the promise that they would see each other again in Christ's presence.
After having given useful spiritual councils to his successor Sirgeus
in the year's 610 through 638, he returned to his monastery.
Towards the end of his life,
Saint Theodore made a further journey to Constantinople
at the invitation of the new emperor Heraclius in the year's 610 through 641,
who asked him to bless his reign.
Returning to Galatia, he was accompanied on the journey by an ever-increasing crowd carrying candles and sensors,
and each one asked the man of God to stop on the way to bless his village,
his field, his house, or his animals.
After he had returned to his monastery,
the mother of God appeared to him and presented him with a precious ring.
From that time onwards, his strength began to fail,
belonging entirely to the world above.
He forgot food here below, falling ill,
he remained for 13 days as if outside himself,
contemplating the mysteries of the world to come.
As soon as he came to himself, he abandoned the solitary life,
and participated with all the zeal of a young novice in the common life.
He would be the first in church and chanted the whole office,
exhorting his monks never to leave the church or to leave aside the divine office,
even when they were ill.
He said to them,
When we enter into the house of the Lord, we rise up to heaven.
We find the celestial king there, surrounded by all his court.
We are enabled to converse trustingly with God,
to ask him directly for all we desire.
One night, St. George appeared to St. Theodore,
and confiding a staff to him, invited him to go with him on a long journey.
The saint celebrated all the services of great week and Easter,
with great joy and gladness.
Then, on Thomas Sunday, which coincided that year,
in the year 613, with the eve of the feast of St. George,
he bade farewell to his disciples.
Assured them of his intercession in God's presence,
if they themselves took care of their own salvation,
and then fell asleep in peace,
to awaken to eternal life.
They clothed him in his episcopal insignia,
over the irons which they were not able to remove.
And after a vigil, which lasted the whole night,
and at which funeral hymns were mixed with hymns
in honor of the great martyr,
who had helped the saint in all his battles,
they placed his body in the tomb.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God,
have mercy on us and save us.